So. When. And.
Where is the problem.
His problem all
and.
Well i'm robyn moore
and i'm a member of rob red community which
is one of the older ones established in
this area we.
Were was established in
nineteen eighty as a
community before that i had
lived on the property.
For a couple of years and
it soon became clear that.
There was an absurdly large amount
of land for a single widow with
at the time. No no family living with me.
And so since i kept meeting young
people in the area who had.
Obviously had skills
and great need for a home base.
I kept thinking well this is would be a
good idea to do to see if we could become a
community and the whole story
of how this has happened is.
As i unfolded over the
last 12 years a couple
first i met.
I had been admiring these
mugs that and jugs
that were in the local craft shop.
And had bought several of them.
Because i just like the the way they
were thrown and the design of them.
And i was at a function in nimbin
where money was being raised
to the person beyond i think
and someone introduced jeff sterling to me
and i realised this is
the name of the potter.
So i got talking with him and
found out that he and his wife
and family were. Just
about to leave the area.
Having been here for a couple of years
and not found any satisfactory place
to live and. It had been for them.
It hadn't been a great success.
So i said hey you know.
We've got some land out
here at lillian rob.
Why don't you come out and have a look.
You know we've been looking for people
especially people like you with.
With skills and who want
to live in the area.
So they thank me very politely
and said well maybe yes.
If we've got time before we leave.
We'll try and get out to you. And.
The next day was sunday i think and we
were having a work day then you know wall
and i think i was up on the
roof painting the roof
and suddenly they should turn up
but definitely he's doing saying hey we
couldn't we couldn't sleep all night
thinking about this. Could we could we come
and see the place and so that was good.
So we brought them out and.
They came and they looked
around and we had lunch and
and i said yes we'd like to
like to take you up on this.
So that was really the beginning. I
mean it really was a pick up wasn't it.
That's it. And.
Well they came a couple of.
They moved over a couple
of months later and.
They've been here ever since
and they've gone through many.
Transfiguration xx. Jeff being a potter.
Polly being a leather craftsman and then.
Weaver.
Dress designer
and now they are the wild turkey felt
makers who were. Exporting their.
Produce products produce sort
of up and down the coast.
You know and running workshops
in still making and
and from from then on there was
a gradual jeff's brother came
and he settled here and.
He's a cabinet maker.
And wanted to others and.
So it grew very slowly and gradually.
And people lived in tents while they
built themselves cabins or shelters.
Do you want me to talk about the.
The process of becoming legal.
Process. Quite.
They as well.
The thing that i felt seemed
to be important was that.
If people.
Needed a place to build a home and needed.
The sort of support. So that
the community can give you.
Those were the very important criteria.
It wasn't so important
that they have money.
That they contribute money to buy shares.
I didn't want money to be the limiting factor
because after all the places paid for.
Anyway. You know i wasn't under
any particular burden of debt.
So that it was a matter of
was more important to. For.
Sort of sympathetic people to get
together. To share the land.
And i think on the whole
it's worked out that way.
And we've only ever had
people come by invitation.
They've been a few who've.
Sort of racked up
and said hey you know i've got i've just
got so much money i want to share here
and we have to say i'm sorry that's not the
way we do things here in fact sometimes
it's it takes it takes
100 per cent approval.
Before any new one can
come on to live here.
As a member
that is.
So i think that was. Yes.
When another idea that i
had at the beginning and.
One reason i was particularly glad
to have polly and this stirling cow.
It was that they were artists
and creative people.
And i had known from my own
parents experience that.
Its very hard often for people who are
creative in this way to acquire much
capital basis.
So i felt that it would be good
if there were more emphasis
or more people who had
these sort of skills
and needed a place to live. I felt
that would be a very important.
Aspect to inviting those
individuals to come and live here.
Mind you it isn't always then
not everybody is that way.
But there are there's
a number of musicians
and a number of craftspeople.
I think probably in every
household there's one or other.
But that
that is only been a fortunate sort of
huge one thing leading to another huge.
Situation. Oh.
Well it's i think the stemmed from.
Knowing that my parents had
their great difficulty and.
In paying rent even and they had to pay
the rent. So most of their married life.
They didn't have enough to put together
you know what was necessary to own their
own home. Oh my father.
Or at all my father is an artist and
my mother was writer and between them
and i knew that they. Had quite a hard
financial struggle and in fact we never.
They never earned their own home
and till i was sort of
in my thirties probably.
So that they were constantly having
to pay rent for a place to live.
And i just felt that.
So people who had these creative skills
and wanted to devote their energies to.
Exploring those skills.
It would be rather good to
allow them to live here
without too much financial
burden for i mean there's no
effective rent or the cost.
Never was to be the important thing is.
Pay back time. And by pay
back do you mean sort of.
I guess trying to make
good. I mean yes. Well.
I think my parents.
I mean they just managed somehow
or other but i just felt
that i didn't want. People.
I just thought it would
be that a better way.
If they didn't have to spend most
of their income paying for rent
and they could use it. In
building a house or garden
or you know helping with their children.
She's not answering it very well is
she.
Up same. Yes.
Oh yes in in. All in this whole area.
Since 1970s 1973 which was
the aquarius the first
aquarius festival time they had
been a number of people becoming.
Interested in building their own homes.
Of course and the home builders
association had become pretty active.
And one of the.
Problems about this was
that there was not much.
Consultation there was no
nothing in the way of.
A manual on how to build your own home
or there was very little literature
around available to help people like
that and there were.
There was one architect and a number
of people who had some skills
and they were very active
that was eddie. Of course.
They were very active in this
home builders association.
And the home builders association.
In conjunction with i
guess lismore council.
Got together this seminar in lismore
in no i think it was about november
1979. I know it was just
before the eighties.
And it at that seminar.
Paul lander who was then the minister
for the environment i think she came
and after a lot of discussion
and a lot of argument
and a lot of opposition
from his not councils and
and other people to
landowners were feeling very.
Threatened by this idea of
multiple occupancies. Paul lander.
Came out with this summation.
Alright we will establish a
pilot scheme of twenty two.
I think it was multiple occupancies which
will be permitted in the list moesha.
Will the stablish a consulting team.
I could take builders who bring out a i
think they brought out a low cost country
housing booklet.
And there was generally a
sort of an overriding of the.
The fears
and the opposition being put up
against multiple occupancies.
And of course for those of us who
had been interested in cane about
stablish ing. This form of land use.
It was a time of.
Euphoria or at least that moment of
euphoria. And as a result of that.
Although we ourselves are not
enlist moesha but in cairo galicia.
I felt that it was only a
matter of time before.
The other shah's would be.
Willing to accept the idea
of multiple occupancy.
And so i felt all right about trying
to go ahead with inviting people
to come and share the land here.
This wasn't i wasn't
unique in this. There was.
There were two or three other
people in the area who were also.
Who owned land who were also doing
this i think i've been lucky that.
The people who have sort of
swam into this area have
somehow or other sort of settled
and. We've been able to be as.
To consolidate the community
as well as we have.
There was a period of course from
from 1980 when the first new.
The first people who my invited here
came to live here in the early 1980s.
There until about nine hundred
eighty six. I think it was 1987.
That we got official recognition of our
right to have a multiple occupancy
on this land. But that was
during the time when council.
Was going through quite a lot of.
Hard searching you could call it.
I suppose about the wisdom of having multiple
occupancies mind you they were having
them anyway they because there was a lot
of people just just settling and living
and building.
And i felt quite sorry for
the council inspectors
and they started sort of telling us their
sad story how you know they they had no
physical way of of even visiting all
these laces let alone inspecting them
properly and assessing
their long term worse.
That ever counts so i think
eventually accepted the proposition
that they would have to
allow multiple occupancies.
They have done it in this in
this corner of their. Sure.
Which used to be part of
the old touraine isha.
And they excluded multiple occupancies
from the rest of the shire.
At least at the beginning. In fact
that i think has probably changed now.
As they've found that we haven't got
you know horns and green tails and
that we are really human beings
too and maybe it's just as.
Adequate a land uses as any
other form of occupancy.
Or. What.
So that's just i think very personal in
my daughter.
When i came to nimbin because
my i guess i must i can't claim
any particular.
Merit out of this my daughter had
been interested in the place
and had been living here
for a couple of years.
My son had been here for the
aquarius festival.
He had old enough i thought to
hitchhike up here from school
with a couple of his friends
but there was no way i was going to
allow my cysteine year old daughter to
come up here on her own hitchhiking so.
I bundled her and a number of her
friends and tent into the car
and we drove up here.
And so i sort of inadvertently i was
that the name is to 1973
although i must confess
that it was not of my initial change.
Although now i'm very glad that i was
experienced at least a little bit of it.
I didn't come back again until
a couple of years later
when i visited my daughter who altered.
I came back to visit my daughter a
couple of times in the succeeding years.
And it was. Of a stimulating
in a very exciting place.
Naturally i was appalled by some of the
sort of conditions the young people were
living in like like my daughter
had her first home consisted of a
piece of plastic.
Pinned up tied up underneath the
lantana bush that she had carved out.
And she was perfectly happy
that i'm glad the stage moved
on slightly grander things and
that but at the time at the
stage she was at that was.
And she was making their good friends
she was happy she was healthy.
And
and i really began to appreciate
something of what this whole area
and philosophy was.
Doing or was about.
And i must state that it was the
young people who sort of told me.
But for them. I would have gone on as a.
Sort of the standard middle class
mum in the suburbs of sydney
much of what was.
Said.
I think the philosophy of.
Trying to be as.
A ride and i think initially
when we first i first came
to live here at rob road.
There was a general feeling
at the end of the 70s
that we should be trying to
live a lot more simply than
we had been living and also
that we should be exploring different
uses of the land. Different uses.
Of agriculture.
Different types of agriculture much
more towards the line of permaculture
and sustainable sort of.
Production rather than the
agricultural monoculture
that is the more general.
Let's see other philosophies tard
when you look this isn't his.
Philosophy sort of grow out
of experienced aren't they
there was a bit of fear. I think i
know amongst some people. That.
There would be a world cup. Lapse. Of.
Supply.
Things like petrol and oil and the fear
that still the fear of nuclear holocaust.
So that to live in a place
that was at least slightly remote.
Slightly more removed from the
centers of socal civilization
seemed to be of positive benefit.
Mind you i don't think
we succeeded very much.
Well i mean it seems to have got closer
and closer to her everything
in the intervening time
and i remember feeling how how
remote it all was at first
and now it just seems as if it's just.
You know just like a suburb
of the whole east coast.
I think that the.
It was it was very much
a social experiment.
If one can use
that word experiment without having
any control system to judge it by
but a social experiment in
seeing how well one could
live. In respect to quality of life.
On very very little money
very little income
and maybe as smug but a sort of feel
when i look when i visit my
friends in the city. With their.
Most of the. Now i've got rid of
their mortgages but only just.
And they've got their
three cars and there.
You know their problems about where they
go this year for their holidays and.
Such concerns. I feel t.
We really have got.
Such a lovely peaceful.
And there is a quality of life here
and we haven't had to go through
those years of she stresses
and trauma that a lot of people has
and i think there is something
coming out of this.
Of course the main i've always said
the main product of this community.
If you if you want to talk about product.
As a as a measure of success.
The product of this
community is its children
and the the children who
are growing up here
and have grown up over the last four years
just seem to be such well-balanced lovely
lively. Unstressed. Young people.
I guess it's early times to say
yet how they'll end up later on.
But
but it's a it's a big group of
children like there are 18.
I think.
And with the eldest being 18 years
old the youngest being one.
That they have. They have
more of a community.
Then they're adults their parents are
really in they they sort of care for each
other they look after each other
and there's a lot of course the
little groups of age range
or sex
that get together like there's a cluster
of little girls about fdr five little
girls all about the same age
and they form the most wonderful
little subgroup amongst them
but on the whole i think you know
if you want to judge a society by
anything. The behavior and. Health of
their children is is one way that.
It could be judged.
To.
Times.
How she smiling.
Oh she she has. My own daughter.
Yes she has.
Well she's she moved in her desires
for home life from sort of the
normal suburban middle class
suburban domestic set up
with her own room and you know.
Washing machines and everything
that was appropriate in in the
suburban household to this shelter
with a sleeping bag underneath a plastic.
Skin plastic sheet.
Tied into a land on a bush.
And then through successive. Homes that
she and her partner has been built.
From you know simple bush
polls two splendid stone.
And tile mansions almost. And then.
She decided. Right.
I want to do something in my life i don't
want to spend my time. Just washing and.
Doing the garden. So she went back
as a mature students and did nursing
and is now working in sydney
as a community nurse.
And they happy.
If she saw the right sort of work
opportunity i think she might is.
Such.
The legal structure right.
Well from 1980 on we gradually.
Came across. People.
In the area who were searching
for a place to live.
And.
Those of us who were
then living on the farm.
More or less decided whether or not
we would invite them to to come
and share the land.